today's report makes for very difficult
reading for the whole of the policing
family and it's clear that there have
been serious failings at a leadership
and cultural level I have to say that
the vast majority of men and women who
wear the badge who serve in our
Metropolitan Police Force are honest
decent Brave professionals who uphold
the highest standards the report is
clear that there are systemic and
chronic problems with leadership and
culture and what we need to do is change
the culture change the practice and
change the systems in place that are
running and regulating the met and that
depends on the leadership and that's why
it's so Mark and Dame Lin have my total
backing in making progress and building
on the progress they've already secured